I don't have a clue what Consciousness
actually is we think we have it and
nematode worms do not my personal
feeling is it does add something to
learning machines
nematodes don't learn much so they don't
need much of a knowledge representation
system sophisticated mammals such as
ourselves not only have to learn about
the world it has to be built into some
knowledge system that we can access and
I suspect it'll be something like a
formal language in our case a natural
language and the knowledge system we've
constructed but of course something like
a narrative it's a story that we tell
ourselves all our lives and everything
we learn is sort of fitted into the
story so we can easily access it later
so my feeling is that is where
Consciousness lies there is no
consciousness without learning and there
is no Learning Without irreversibility
and that's how I would like to approach
a theory of Consciousness but as a
humble physicist of course that's not my
job
foreign